c'est ton guerrier
ton arme hé pas de sueur classe gagne un
homme cesse qu'est ce que tu fais dans ma
chambre
eh bien comment suis-je entré dans cette chambre d'
hôtel merdique parce que je suis un vrai espion je
pensais que tu arrêtais nous devons arrêter la
vente d'un  une bombe nucléaire et ils envoient
quelqu'un qui ressemble à la
[ __ ] de femme du Père Noël ah avez-vous oublié que je suis
sous couverture parce que vous n'êtes pas
censé être ici vous pensez vraiment que vous êtes prêt
pour le terrain
J'ai déjà utilisé des défibrillateurs sur moi-même ou
mis des éclats de  verre d'un [ __ ] d'œil
j'ai sauté d'un immeuble de grande hauteur en
utilisant seulement un imperméable comme parachute et je me suis
cassé les deux jambes à l'atterrissage et j'ai encore
dû faire semblant d'être dans un [ __ ]
de spectacle du Cirque de Soleil d'avaler assez de
micropuces et de les chier  redescendez
pour faire un ordinateur ce bras a été
complètement arraché et recollé
avec ce [ __ ] de bras un autre c'est
possible Romaric Lee